foreign
foreign
good morning we'll wait one more minute
until
speakers enter the room
um
so the sitting
is open
um
threshold so the Committees May
therefore start the negotiations the
first item on the agenda this morning is
the council and commission statements
preparation of the European council
meeting of the 20th and the 21st October
2022 I start by giving the floor to the
minister for European Affairs of the
Czech Republic on behalf of the
councilashbeck Nicola
president metal arm President Van Der
Lyon honorable members tomorrow and
Friday leaders will meet in Brussels for
the October European Council starting
with the usual exchange with European
Parliament president metzola
leaders will discuss Russia's escalatory
war of aggression against Ukraine and
its consequences including the situation
in Global Food security or the impact on
Energy prices and on our economy
they will also address relations with
China and with asean
less than two weeks ago leaders met in
Prague for an informal European council
meeting to discuss these topics and
prepare the ground for the debates that
will take place in Brussels this week
the Steep increase in Energy prices
touches all European citizens and
businesses and is therefore high on the
agenda of the European Council
as we know Russia is weaponizing energy
in an attempt to weaken the resolve and
economic power of the European Union
we will not let this happen
building on their discussions in Prague
as well as yesterday's commission
proposal
leaders will speak a strong common
European response to the high gas and
electricity prices
there is a broad agreement on key areas
of action to lower prices
but there are still some divergences on
the how that will be for leaders to
discuss
I can nonetheless already share some key
messages
first we will not allow Russia's
weaponizing of energy to weaken the
resolve and economic power of the EU
second
key areas for action will include
efforts to reduce demand to ensure
security of supply
and to lower energy prices
leaders will also address the latest
developments in Russia's escalating war
of aggression against Ukraine which is
putting European and Global Peace and
security at risk
this includes Russia's missile attacks
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure in Kiev and across
Ukraine its actions at Ukraine's
zaparusia nuclear facility and the
illegal annexation by Russia of
Ukraine's Donetsk luhansk zaporizia and
Carson regions
leaders will reiterate their unwavering
support for Ukraine's Independence
sovereignty and territorial integrity
Ukraine has the right to liberate and
regain full control of all occupied
territories within its internationally
recognized borders
as already stated by leaders on the 30s
of September the European Council
unequivocally condemns and rejects
Russia's illegal annexation of Ukraine's
Donetsk luhansk the parisia and Hassan
regions the European Council will call
for Russia to immediately completely and
unconditionally withdraw all of its
troops and military equipment from the
entire territory of Ukraine and refrain
from hybrid attacks on Ukraine
there is growing evidence of war crimes
committed in Ukraine we have also seen
the continuous destruction of Civilian
infrastructure in the country
these are gross violations of
international law
leaders are expected to call for holding
Russia to account
as you know the European Union will
stand with you crying for as long as it
takes it will continue to provide
political military financial and
humanitarian support to Ukraine
leaders are expected to call for the
Speedy adoption of the remaining 3
billion Euro in microfinancial
assistance for Ukraine
ahead of the conference in Berlin on the
25th of October
2022 the European Council will discuss
the governance and financing of
reconstruction efforts
Russia's war of aggression has sparked a
global food crisis driving up world food
and fertilizers prices
the EU will continue to facilitate the
export of Ukrainian agricultural
products where the EU solidarity lanes
and Global access to agricultural
products and fertilizers for the
country's most in need
the European Council will also discuss
recent acts of sabotage against critical
infrastructure such as those against the
north stream Pipelines
we will meet any deliberate disruption
of critical infrastructure or other
hybrid actions with a United and
determined response and continue to
strengthen our preparedness
Rising Energy prices have a big economic
impact on the EU we are committed to
coordinating closely our policy
responses
our priority is to protect the most
vulnerable in our societies while
preserving Europe's Global
competitiveness and maintaining the
Level Playing Field and the Integrity of
the single Market
another pressing crisis is climate
change the European Council will discuss
preparations for the upcoming cop 27
and leaders are expected to stress the
extreme urgency of strengthening the
global response to address the climate
emergency in the face of increasingly
intense and frequent extreme weather
events
ahead of the 15 Conference of the
parties to the convention on biological
diversity in Montreal the European
Council will also call for the adoption
of an ambitious comprehensive and
transformative post-2020 Global
biodiversity framework to hold and
reverse biodiversity loss
in the field of external relations
leaders are expected to have a strategic
discussion on China
they will also look ahead to the
upcoming EU asan commemorative Summit on
the 14th of December which will be an
opportunity to further deepen the EU
strategic partnership with Assam
thank you for your attention
thank you very much Mr Beck and now I
invite the commission president Ursula
on the line to take the floor
thank you
thank you president
Roberta dear Minister Beck
honorable members
yesterday we saw again Russia's targeted
attacks against civilian infrastructure
and this is marking a new chapter in an
already very cruel War
the international order is very clear
these are war crimes
targeted attacks on civilian
infrastructure with a clear aim to cut
off men women children of water
electricity and heating with the winter
coming these are acts of pure Terror
and we have to call it as such
this is a moment to stay the course and
we will back Ukraine for as long as it
takes
and we will protect Europeans from the
other world that Putin is waging this is
his war on our energy
I know that Europeans are concerned
concerned about inflation
concerned about their energy bills
concerned about the winter
the best response to Putin's gas
blackmail
is European solidarity and European
Unity
and in this spirit
in this Spirit the commission agreed
yesterday on a strong legislative
framework to address the energy crisis
so let me outline the main points to you
the first one is as logic as important
instead of outbidding each other
Europeans should buy gas together very
simple
so for this we will purchase together
gas at EU level
aggregation of demand will be mandatory
for at least 15 percent of the volumes
needed to fill gas storages
and the companies involved may form a
gas purchasing Consortium
we do this because we've learned the
lesson we literally saw in August of
this year at the height of the filling
season how member states were out
bidding each other and thus driving
really up the prices so we definitely
can be smarter on that one
pooling our demand is a must
my next point is about sharing Us in
Europe
we know that some member states are more
directly exposed than others to Russian
gas situation especially challenging for
landlocked countries in Central Europe
but in the end if you look at our single
Market with highly integrated Supply
chains
A disruption in one member state has a
massive impact on all member states so
sharing us is absolutely critical
member states have already since five
years an obligation under EU law to
conclude solidarity agreements with
their neighbors in the region where they
are located however if you look at what
has been concluded so far
of 40 possible solidarity agreements
only six have been concluded so this is
simply not enough in times of a crisis
like this one
and this is why we will put in place
default rules for member states
these rules will be binding as long as
member states do not conclude individual
solidarity agreement
energy solidarity is a fundamental
principle of our treaties so let's bring
that to life it's very simple
honorable members these three measures
pooling saving sharing
will have a positive impact on the
prices
but of course more needs to be done
more needs to be done to address the
price spikes and to address the Russian
manipulation of the energy Market
just to give you two figures
compared to last September in September
2021 if we look now at September 2022
Russia has cut 80 percent of its
pipeline gas supplies since then
but Europe has been able to compensate
all that we have Diversified towards our
trusted Partners like for example
nowhere in the United States we have
increased the savings and it's good we
have in September a saving of minus 15
percent
we have filled our storages up to 92
percent
so we did not give in to this blackmail
we made it and I think we can be proud
of that we resist it that's important
but we also see
that resisting the Russian energy
coercion comes at a price
European families have seen their gas
bill skyrocketing
and our companies are struggling to keep
up competitiveness
it's not about the competitive in the
single Market only that's also important
but it's also about the competitiveness
globally that our companies are fighting
for
you might recall that in March we
proposed to counsel the option to cap
gas prices
at that time this did not gain any
traction
but today we're coming back to this
so what is the model
the current Benchmark determining gas
prices
is ttf
ttf is only focused on Pipeline gas
what we see now is that the market has
really changed from pipeline gas market
to LNG market so we need a new a
specific price Benchmark for LNG
the commission will now develop this
complementary Benchmark together with
the European regulator but this takes
time
so in the meantime as a stop Gap measure
we will limit prices at ttf we call this
the market correction mechanism
yesterday we proposed guiding principles
as a first step and on this basis we
will prepare the operational mechanism
in a second step
this is concerning the price cap at
wholesale level
but gas also drives electricity prices
up
and here the Iberian model comes into
play
it really merits to be considered at EU
level
there are still questions to be answered
but I want to leave no stone unturned so
let's face that let's look at that and
let's work at that
honorable members
we live in times of high economic
uncertainty
I said concerned about the
competitiveness of our economy not only
what the single Market is concerned
but also what the global competitiveness
of our that our economy is concerned so
all our actions have to take this into
account all our actions have to take the
competitiveness of our smes and our
industry into account
and this includes that we will introduce
a standard competitiveness check in our
regulation I think it is time to do that
in addition
in addition we have to speed up
Investments all over Europe and if I
speak about investment it's
infrastructure it is Energy Efficiency
and it is Renewables
and this brings me to repower EU
when we propose repower EU in March
keep in mind the situation was as such
there was a huge dependency of Russian
gas
at that time we anticipated that it
would take several years to replace the
Russian gas
fact is today it took us eight months
only to replace two-thirds
in other words we have massively
accelerated the diversification to other
suppliers of gas from abroad
but this comes as a hype at a high price
so the actual solution to maintain our
competitiveness is to invest into
home-grown sources of energy specially
Renewables and that has to happen in all
of Europe
however
only member states with sufficient
fiscal space can undertake these
critical Investments
so this will inevitably unlevel the
playing field of our single Market
and therefore we do not only need
re-power EU now so we have to accelerate
it but we have to boost it we have to
increase its Firepower and we will come
with a proposal on that because it will
give every member State the same
opportunity to prepare for the future
this is not only about energy
this is about our Global competitiveness
and that it is about our sovereignty
Long Live Euro many things
[Applause]
thank you very much
commission president I give the floor
now to the group leaders starting with
the leader of the Epp group Mumford
weather
president from the line Mr Beck
on Monday morning Russia attacked Kiev
again with nearly 30 drones killing
innocence including a pregnant woman